I'm ready to open up my heart and I'm
hoping that all these women are ready to
do the exact same thing with me while
these 30 women are hoping their hearts
will take flight I had such an insane
such an amazing group of women that I
felt and I fell for multiple people can
of Browns appearance on Peter Webber's
season of The Bachelor is already
causing some turbulence as you and I
talked about you're like I least filming
Dancing with the Stars yeah so we'll see
how much your honor yeah but I also feel
like with you if you're on for a little
bit you make a big impression planes
windmills and yes even more planes took
over the first night at the bachelor
mansion hopefully you could save room
for another Hannah in your heart yeah I
think I can
Peter handed out the first impression
rose to Hannah Anne but the most
exciting moment of the season premiere
was pilot Pete's reunion with Hannah be
Alabama Hannah stepped out of the limo
and we saw Peter's jaw-dropping reaction
oh I'm nervous but she didn't stop by
just to talk about old times she also
came offering a gift you gave me
something Oh
I want you to find that person and so I
brought these back every you know
wondering where these were at the end of
the three-hour episode Peter and Hannah
sit down for a heart-to-heart
do you regret sending me home at all
okay yeah Peter I question it all the
time though it looks like this pair has
a little more to hash out next week I'm
obviously not 100% where I thought I was
ET spoke with Peter before the premiere
and he shared how he felt about
tonight's surprise reveal that was
unexpected for me I did not know what
she was coming that first night and she
shows up opens that door I didn't even
realize was her at first and then I
noticed it's her she's kind of walking
closer or out of the car and you know I
thought I genuinely thought when I
decided yeah it would be the bachelor
that I was in a spot where I could do
that and I was ready and I had moved on
I really did think that she says she
shows up that first night and I started
to question that Chris Harrison also
weighed in on the highly anticipated
moment her and Peter they just they just
have this thing that intangible kind of
chemistry and it's one of those things
that no matter how much you think you're
over somebody when you see each other
it's a thing it's still a thing and it's
not to say you know look is he over her
is she over him I'm not gonna get into
that I'll let them deal with that on the
show but it's a thing and there is some
serious chemistry between the two that's
just undeniable and that's why we wanted
to have her back on the show it's not
just a hey I'm here to hit you on the
shoulder and say good luck it's more
than that so will Peter Webber find love
at the end of all this I can say I am
very happy with everything I did and I'm
excited that there's a reason that no
one's gonna find out the ending
[Music]